what I was curious about with carpool
karaoke is you wouldn't answer who the
best carpool karaoke guest was isn't
that true you in other words you avoided
saying who the very best was well it's
not but I could say who my favorite was
my my favorite for sure all my car yeah
you know I understand why the Paul
McCartney want would be your I mean a
guy from England and you probably
worship the Beatles as much as I do yeah
it's just mind-blowing that you're
sitting there doing let it be in
Liverpool in Liverpool with Paul
McCartney cried yeah it was emotional no
what happened
I couldn't believe that I was I remember
when I was doing it thinking I don't
know what I've done to deserve such
memories I don't know what I don't know
what has gone right that I would that I
would have such memories all of it
everything the show the Tonys but like
there in Liverpool and thinkers we you
know there was like some jetlag involved
in you you're flying and then we got up
to Liverpool and and then we're there
and we're doing it and I just had this
overwhelming feeling of like my my
grandfather was a musician who I'm
pretty sure introduced the Beatles to me
and with with my dad at the time and
just had this overwhelming feeling of
like this if he could see this if he
could just get the Opera if he had the
opportunity to shake the man's hand it
would have made his week is month his
year and here are my singing these very
songs and it just I couldn't help it you
came I could it over whelmed me in the
whole moment and the the brilliance of
the man of Paul was when I said to him
and I was shocked by it I'm not someone
who's like so quick to be that emotional
he driving around it's just me and him
in a car and I said I didn't expect that
and he said that's the power of music
and I and I said to him I if my grandad
was here he'd get a real kick out of
this and he just went here's like and
before that he told a story which I
hadn't heard before of how let it be
counting that he'd had this vision of
his of his mother Mary
saying just let it be let it light and
the whole thing you're like I don't know
I've never I'd heard the phrase I
stopped traffic before and I'd never
really understood it until like walking
down Penny Lane with suppor McCartney
and every single car at the junction is
stopped and you cannot hear a single
horn
no one is beeping their horn because
they're just going oh my god I don't
believe it and you're like what this is
madness